ثمه ما يجتمع عليه هؤلاء انه كنز من ماء
بئر بعد طول عناء ازمه انقطاع المياه في
السودان تدفع هؤلاء الى الامر مياه عكره
باتت بفعل الحرب صالحه للشرب فلا خيار اخر
يخاطر مدنيون في سبيل البحث عن الماء تشهد
المنطقه هنا وسط الخرطوم معارك محتدمه لم
يترك الرصاص شيئا الا وعليه اثره
رجع جنب الفيل وقع جنبك رعينا اخيرا يعود
بعضهم محملين بما لا يروي ولا يغني من عطش
اما على الضفه هنا نهر على سعته يلجاون
اليه يحتفظون بماء النهر حيله قد تعينهم
لايام بعد معارك سببت نقصا في المياه
الصالحه للشرب
من الصباح بعد الاح حصلت دي انقطعت تماما
المويه ونحن من سبعه صباحا بنكون في شوارع
ما بنلقى جرد المويه لحدي اذان الظهر شحوا
المياه يضرب العاصمه الخرطومه بعد معارك
بين الجيش السوداني والدعم السريع استهدفت
محطات المياه
محطات يصعب الوصول لها واصلاحها لاستمرار
الصراع في محيطها
فيما طالبت منظمه الصحه بوقف فوري لاطلاق
النار خوفا من تداعيات انسانيه قد تكون
الاسوا في تاريخ السودان غيداء السالم
العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات